il s'est appelé au cours de son
existence la grange de doueir puis le
normandie avant de devenir le grenier à
sel à la fin des années 1970
l'activité cinématographique de ce lieu
emblématique de trappes et démarre après
la première guerre mondiale mais son
histoire remonte à bien plus loin
les prémices de ce bâtiment le plus
vieux de la ville sont visibles à la fin
du moyen-âge le grenier est alors un
dépôt de celles collectées par un impôt
la gabelle ce bâtiment elle a participé
à la à la gabelle donc à la à l'impôt
sur le sel est là la grandeur de cette
bâtisse nous laissant entendre que
c'était un lieu de stockage le sien lieu
de vente
le site devient ensuite au xvième siècle
une poste aux chevaux un service de
relais pour le transport des voyageurs
et leurs bagages
l'histoire du grenier à sel est en fait
liée à celle de l'étoile d'or l'auberge
attenante
en 1919 le propriétaire du lieu demande
à la mairie l'autorisation de créer une
activité cinéma fixe à une époque où les
projections sont plutôt itinérante
les premières séances ont lieu dès 1920
la grosse activité cinéma démarre
officiellement avec en 1945 à la sortie
de la guerre où le cinéma ou la grange
devient le normandie le cinéma le
normandie et le normandie s'arrête
en 1975 puis 6 puis le bâtiment est
repris par la ville
restauration en 1979 qui laisse
apparaître les pierres meulières du
bâtiment encore visibles aujourd'hui un
lieu avant tout d'innovation
technologique le cinéma inaugure en 1964
un écran révolutionnaire le deuxième du
type installé dans le monde l'heracles
orama c'était un écran courbes avec des
lamelles en métal qui permettait d'avoir
avec un certain objectif qui permettait
d'avoir une impression de profondeur
donc on pouvait projeter n'importe quel
film du commerce et avoir une impression
de profondeur s'était pas le relief
encore mais c'était déjà une grande
avancée technologique en 2012 le grenier
à sel s'équipe d'un projecteur 4k l'une
des premières salles à se convertir à
l'ultra haute définition elle malgré son
grand âge le cinéma de trappes n'a cessé
de se renouveler un oeil toujours tourné
vers l'avenir